well Ben this seems like that pistol
everybody hears here okay well first of
all thanks for coming to this late
afternoon session I realized the end of
a long day so I'm going to try and keep
this particular talk relatively
lightweight and kind of a overview
filled with name-dropping rather than
with real theorems but in the subsequent
lectures I will try and delve more into
the technical content so normally I
thank the organizers for inviting me to
give a talk but I'm one of the damned
organizers and I feel like now
chastising myself and my fellow
organizers for coming up with this
bright idea of giving five talks in a
row but anyway here we are committed to
do it so let's tags oki on right so as
folk eon mentioned earlier part of the
purpose of this program is to bring
together the different strands but not
just the different strands within the
program but also to make connections
with the other strand running in
parallel on uncertainty in algorithms so
perhaps the probabilistic strand within
our program is the one that connects
most but as you will see it's actually
very different from the kind of work
that goes on and algorithmic probable is
probabilistic algorithmics so here's a
quick overview of the talk that I'll
give today I'll say a bit about
programming languages for probabilistic
programming I was very fortunate to have
the whole boot camp kicked off by
professor Scott and his call to arms to
develop a formalism for reasoning about
probabilistic programs and giving a
semantics to it so I'll talk about these
early programming languages say
something about probabilistic transition
systems and then a bit more about recent
developments and finally I will say
what's in the course okay so why
probability so James Clark Maxwell is
famously said to have called probability
the true logic of the world and this was
of course in 1850 and of course he made
fundamental contributions to the use of
probability in statistical physics
apart from inventing electrodynamics so
Clark Maxwell's quote here I find very
compelling because it's really telling
you that if you're dealing with the real
world you have to deal with uncertainty
and the only well grounded formalism we
have to tackle uncertainty is the
calculus of probabilities so this is
Berkeley and you know when I was growing
up I was listening to a song called the
Age of Aquarius so it turns out recently
well also recently maybe 10 years ago
David Mumford a well-known feels
medalist in algebraic geometry started
became a convert to this theory of
probability and he wrote a paper called
the dawning of the age of stochasticity
in which he argued that in fact
old-fashioned boolean logic is not the
proper foundation for mathematics it
should be based on probability ok so I
won't read out the quotes but if you
just google dawning of the age of
stochasticity you will get a link to
Mumford's paper in fact Mumford is
reputed to have told people when he was
deep in his algebraic geometry phase
that probability theory is all rubbish
and is not interesting and he he
publicly admits that this was a big
mistake and he recanted that really now
espouses probability as a fundamental
way of thinking about what mathematics
and the natural world so one of the
things that I find when I got into
probability was the thing that jumped
out at me was a notion of conditional
probability and to me this is the
probabilistic analog of the basic notion
of logical inference which is the engine
by which we make deductions so in
ordinary logic we have this notion of P
and P implies Q leading to this new
deduction Q which can be written either
the rule or as a formula and now in the
probabilistic world you introduce the
notion of conditional probability which
can also be written in an hour in this
form and it's suggestive it says that
the probability of both a and B it can
be obtained by the conditional
probability of a given that B has
happened together with the probability
be so here again what does conditional
probability is doing is saying now
you've learned something you learned
that B happened how do you revise your
estimates of the probability for a okay
so this whole notion of conditioning is
a very evocative of how logical
inference happens and it becomes an
important feature of probabilistic
programming languages as they are now
emerging so conditioning sorry no please
don't read anything into things like
that so as I said before conditioning
allows you to revise your probability
estimates as you gain information and
there is this thing that's a grandiose
Lee called Bayes theorem but it's
basically just a rewriting of that
formula but it what it tells you is how
to revise your estimates of the
probabilities of certain hypotheses he's
holding as you make observations okay so
this formula basically says you start
out with some assumption about a certain
hypothesis being true a certain
probability estimate for how it is true
you make some observations and then you
revise that a probability estimate given
that you've actually made a specific
observation now of course you can ask in
this base formula what happens if the
probability of b is 0 now of course in
the discrete world you can say well
probability of b greater than 0 strictly
greater than 0 as a side condition to
that because if probability of b is 0
then it can't have happened so you can't
be talking about the probability of a
given B now but this is a very naive
point of view in the continuous world it
very much often happens that one of the
variables that you're looking at is a
continuous variable the probability of
any one specific value is 0 yet you have
to yet you make an observation you get a
value and you have to revise your
probability estimates so you need some
new machinery to deal with that which
comes about when you start looking at
probability theory on continuous basis
and that will be a significant part of
the mathematical stuffed
I have to expound tomorrow okay so and
continuous basis you cannot just dismiss
this case so you need conditional
probability distributions or as they
called regular conditional probability
distributions and somewhat charmingly
they're also called disintegrations in
contrast with integration nothing is
collapsing so so that's a kind of
overview so let me just very quickly
real recapitulate very basic definition
so that we're all on the same page so
basic discrete probability you have a
finite set called the sample space
subsets are called events and you have a
function that assigns probabilities
elements of s and hence two events
because then probabilities of an events
are just obtained by summing up the
probability of the individual members of
each one of those components of the set
event a random variable is just a
function doesn't have to be real valued
but let's just take it to be real valued
which maps s to R and what happens is
that when you have such a random
variable on a space on which a
probability distribution is defined it
induces a probability measure on the
reals ok so you get a probability
distribution induced on X simply by this
standard formula basically you look at
the inverse image of asset in our and
ask which are the points that could have
landed you in there and you measure them
according to the probability
distribution on your sample space
somewhat charmingly probabilistic eynde
of notation for this talking about
random variables and their probabilities
it tends to violently conflict with the
way measure theorists and analysts use
their notations for talking about
measuring probability but then as
somebody said probability theory is
measured theory with soul so this is the
perhaps the more soulful way of writing
probability expressions a very
fundamental concept is independence we
say two events are independent if their
probabilities of both of them happening
just the product so they don't interfere
with each other in any way and again two
random variables are independent roughly
speaking of the induced probability
distributions are
so you know as I said conditioning is
important so what can talk about
conditional random varies the
independence of random variables
conditioned on a third so if we have
three random variables XY and z we say x
and y are independent conditional on z
if this particular formula holds so if
you look at the conditional
probabilities they factorize ok and it
might well be that the probabilities
themselves do not the perhaps are
correlated because they both depend on Z
but once you fix that they become
independent so this notion of
conditional independence is actually a
very important thing and it's become
crucial in machine learning if you have
three or more variables you can define
pairwise independence and mutual
independence and just as a curiosity
these are not necessarily the same so
here is a simple example supposing I
take two tosses of a fair coin so this
defines my sample space and I look at
the following three events the first
event says the first toss is an H and I
don't care what the second toss is B
says the second toss is a heads and I
don't care what the first horses and see
says the two tosses give the same result
now all three of these events have
probability a half if you look at the
probability of any pair of them it's a
quarter so they're pairwise independent
however the probability of all three of
them is also a quarter and not an eighth
so they're not completely independent
it's just pairwise independence okay so
this was a simple but curious example
that often people seemed not to realize
so probabilistic models become important
reasoning under uncertainty involves the
interplay between independence and
conditioning and a very powerful
formalism invented by people in a I
called Bayes nets allow you to work with
probabilistic models representing
precisely these two key features
independence and particularly
conditional independence and how to
compute marginal probabilities in a
simple and efficient way so the hugely
successful framework is called graphical
models I'm not sure if it was invented
by
pearl but certainly highly popularized
by pearl and Gousha is nodding
vigorously so as you invented by pearl
bring a work for this for well so I know
he pushed the theory a lot I'm not sure
he if he wrote down the first one but it
doesn't matter more or less invented
Viper but Marco networks and so on
exists at being considered earlier okay
so so we have this framework for
representing Bay's nets and what happens
is that this conditional independence
structure captures the crucial features
of the model in a compact way and it's
so useful for computing both marginal
distributions and conditional
probabilities efficiently so these
models are indeed useful for many
situations but one important thing is
that they are not compositional and they
often flatten out the structure inherent
in a situation okay and so one of the
criticisms that emerged in fact from the
machine learning community is that these
are these models are great when you have
them and you know you kind of build them
from scratch but if I have a couple of
these mortals and I want to combine them
how do I compose them so perhaps you
might have a sub graph that's repeated
many times in a regular pattern and
you'd like to say something like oh this
is I need some kind of iteration
construct to repeat this so a new hope
emergence from the theory of programming
languages because if I can say one thing
that programming language semantics is
about it's about looking for structure
and come and composition in fact the
second workshop in this thematic
semester is called compositionality no
sorry the third one third one the second
one is called symmetry the first one I
should say is called uncertainty and
many of the things that I mentioning
today the speakers at that uncertainty
workshop will be elaborating on some of
the points that I make today so here's
this new hope use the theory of
programming languages to give a
structural way of presenting and
reasoning compositionally about
probabilistic models so they
is what I'm hoping will emerge from this
whole theory of probabilistic
programming languages other things have
happened since let's say 1985 one of the
pioneers in reasoning about
probabilistic systems was Moshe vardi
who in 1985 considered mortal checking
of probabilistic systems and
subsequently they have been hugely
successful developments so I guess
Martok witkowsky who will also be at the
uncertainty workshop developed a highly
successful system called prism which
with which he has performed many
industrial strength case studies for
reasoning about probabilistic systems
and others named there have also
developed a theory of probabilistic
verification Jane Hillston wrote a
landmark thesis over 20 years ago using
a compositional probabilistic process
algebra for analyzing performance of
computer systems again in a
compositional way so again the theme of
compositionality is very fundamental
probabilistic transition systems were
studied by several people Kim Larson
honest co phan gråvik and various others
and concepts like by simulation and so
on which I will be talking about in
lecture for at some length came out of
this work around 20 years ago a number
of people started looking at probability
theory in this sense of probabilistic
transition systems on continuous state
spaces so at this so I guess one of the
early papers on this was a paper we
wrote in licks 1997 and I get another
one in 98 where we started looking at
what why simulation was improved a
logical characterization of by
simulation for these continuous state
spaces and others got involved notably
Mike miss love sitting in the back there
and his postdocs and coworkers
one of the things that came out from
studying probability and other kinds of
quantitative theories is that the
algebra of programs is typically stated
in some kind of equation system you say
this and this this program is equivalent
to that one we stop saw folk eons
lectures in relational algebra where
essentially you are making equation all
statements about transforming one
expression to the other well you have
this quantitative kind of setting and
you start talking about equations it
becomes a bit suspect because you put
turb the description of the model just
slightly and then suddenly you say aha
these things are not equivalent anymore
because the numbers don't match exactly
and you wouldn't like to just say oh no
they're not equivalent anymore you'd
rather say they're close by even if
they're not exactly equivalent and so
one is led to the notion of using
metrics and approximations to reason
about probabilistic and other
quantitative systems one of the vexing
problems and I say vexing advisedly is a
combining probability and unquantified
non determinism and this has led to a
lot of complicated and difficult to read
papers by various people I mean they're
difficult to read because the subject is
intrinsically hard not because it's not
presented well but they've been a lot of
interesting developments Mike miss love
again was one of the pioneers in this
work so let me say a bit now about
probability theory and domains Mike will
be giving a talk tomorrow at the end of
the day on this subject so i won't say
much just historical remarks at this
point so hype jeremy in 1978 developed
probabilistic lcf so lcf is the logic of
computable functions which was
originally developed by Dana Scott and
then pushed by Robin Milner and analyze
a great length by Gordon Plotkin in the
context of lcf as a programming language
so I hope Jeremy around that time in
fact developed a probabilistic variant
of lcf and in order to understand
the semantics of this language which he
had to develop probability distributions
on top of domain structure so domain
structure is the kind of mathematical
partially ordered sets that one finds
essential to give semantics to the
lambda calculus and now what we see here
was this new feature higher-order
language but prob what with
probabilities only at Ground type but
already the combination of higher type
abstraction and probability is occurring
about a decade after that Claire Jones
and Gordon Plotkin developed the
probabilistic power domain which they
intended to use to give a full-blown
higher type probabilistic programming
language this power domain was a
fantastic technical achievement but this
also was problematic Regina ticks and a
commune showed that this was again a
vexing construction so basically there
is no known Cartesian closed category
suitable for programming language
semantics in which this probabilistic
power domain is closed so it's it's it's
there but it's and and it's kind of like
a shining beacon of achievement but it
also doesn't fit well with how we like
to think about programming languages at
higher types and above it a lot also
extended integration theory on two
domains back in 81 Dexter cozen gave a
simple semantics for a language with
while loops so in this language you had
just an ordinary assignment statement
you had sequential composition a
conditional and the while loop and so
the question was how does one give
semantics to this so you notice there's
nothing probabilistic in the language
itself but the intention was the
variables are not described by actual
values but perhaps governed by
probability distributions and you want
to know how are those distributions
transformed by the execution of the
program ok if you wish you can add some
kind of random choice construct to the
language it's not at all difficult I
not to do it here functions on
interpreted or what what is Wesley you
imagine that there's some stock of
standard functions that you're using
yeah like some arithmetic and so on
which I didn't want to yeah but you mean
you can make this language as rich as
you like by enriching that F but yes
some some let's say some generic f's
that allow you to do basic arithmetic
already you have to deal with all kinds
of interesting things so the first thing
to note is you might say look I learned
probability theory by tossing dice and
tossing coins rolling dice and tossing
coins and it was a completely adequate
why do I need all this fancy measure
theory that you're talking about as soon
as you introduce something like a while
loop or recursion you are going to get
into the realm of probability theory and
continuous state spaces so you have no
choice it's going to happen anyway so
the semantics which I will describe in
lecture 3 in some detail I'll just say
roughly what it does here is that the
program's transform input distributions
to output distributions so they are
distribution transformers and in this
sense you can think of them as what we
often call state transformer semantics
in operational semantics you have some
description of the state of a program by
telling you for example what the values
of variables are you execute some code
the variables get updated in some way
and this semantic description of the
language simply tells you this is how a
state transforms to a new state for this
particular construct so cozen semantics
was exactly in that spirit but he also
gave a so-called backward semantics
where you look at expectation values of
functions on the state as they transform
backwards so if I tell you the
expectation value of a certain function
after a program fragment is executed I
can then infer what the expectation
value was before okay and so this gives
you a kind of backward flow semantics
and if you're familiar with programming
languages there's this thing called
weakest preconditions semantics that
Dykstra invented for reasoning about
programs imperative programs and so this
is the probabilistic analog of that so
both these things were in Dexter Cozens
original paper and there were many
contributions thereafter from the Oxford
group headed by tony hoare and several
of his co-workers and Carol Morgan and
Annabelle Micawber are still very active
in this area of reasoning about
probabilistic programs so around 1997
saraswat Gupta and jagadeesan combined
probability with the concurrent
constraint programming paradigm which
you may or may not have heard of so
we'll give you a small summary of it
presently and later on we threw out
Vijay and added me and added recursion
so we showed that there was some
interesting computational effects that
had no pure measure Theory counterpart
so I'm going to spend a lot of time
talking about measure theory in this
sequence of lectures but I have to say
right up front I think measure theory is
the wrong thing it has some fundamental
flaws one of them is things are always
defined up two sets of measure zero and
you're always wondering about things
being almost everywhere true etc and
there seems to me it seems to me the one
should be working with other with other
ways of doing it okay so what was
interesting about this concurrent
constraint paradigm is conditioning
became very explicit in the framework as
I will show you in a minute the paper at
that time was largely ignored but that
now is a good time to revive it in that
case so here is a kind of cartoon
picture of how the concurrent constraint
paradigm works there is you might think
of this cloud as being a store which is
just first out of formula so these are
facts that you add to let's call it a
collection of
or of facts okay so various processes
interact with this store so these ovals
represent processes that are interacting
with the store and they do not interact
directly with each other the concurrency
is mediated through their interaction
with the store what do they do with the
store they ask whether the store entails
a particular formula so you can say i
ask is x positive or is x equal to y and
if so then do something otherwise
suspend and wait so you see that ask
construct is kind of a synchronizer it
tells you wait until this is true okay
it's not a conditional in the
traditional sense of if this is true do
this if not do something else know if
it's if this is true you get to go ahead
otherwise you are suspended and stopped
they can also tell formula so they can
add a new formula to the store so the
store is actually growing it's not like
in a functional language immune to side
effects it is being side affected but in
benign way the information content of
the store is always increasing in a
normal imperative program when you do
things like X gets one you're not just
updating the value of x you're also
killing the old value of x okay so
you're destroying information as well
that's never happening in this in this
particular setting and how do we know
whether the formula in the store and
tails the formula you're asking about we
abstract away from that we pretend
there's this demon who answers the
entailment queries of course it's a
fascinating subject about the algorithm
makes of answering constraint queries
what we're abstracting away from that
and just saying somehow this demon
answers entailment queries so that's the
a scale model so this is the syntax for
the the CCP processes you can ask a
formula you can tell a formula you can
run two processes in parallel and then
you can have a fresh local variable
which we call new XO the scope of this
new variable X is is P and so you can
introduce fresh variables into the store
you can then impose constraints on it
and so on
and we add recursion as well so it turns
out sorry that there's a very nice
semantics for this programming language
in terms of what I call closure
operators so the set of storage forms a
complete algebraic lattice and programs
what they do is they can only improve
the information content of these stores
and so they are modeled as continuous
closure operators on top of that lattice
now for the probabilistic variant you
add this new construct choose X from
some finite domain and so this variable
X again is a local variable whose scope
is P but now it's assigned value that's
randomly selected perhaps uniformly from
some domain D ok so these things should
not have been called random variables
but at that time we were so naive that's
what we call them so each of these
variables has its own independent
probability distribution and you might
think it's very limiting that you're
always only using the uniform
distribution but in fact by judicious
use of constraints you can show that you
can get any distribution you want as
long as the probabilities in question or
rational so conditioning and constraints
interact like this so you can do things
like choose X from this set so the
probability of getting one of those
values is a quarter but then you can
impose this constraint X has to be less
than 2 less than or equal to 2 and then
you can have these two things running in
parallel ask this in which case you add
a to the store or ask that in which case
you add B to the store they're both
sitting there so depending on what value
gets assigned to X then one or other of
those things will trigger you might note
that it's possible that X gets the value
3 whereas which will of course flatly
contradict this constraint in which case
the store is set to become inconsistent
and we kind of discard those stores and
normalize renormalize the
the probabilities okay good so that's a
an example of a concurrent constraint
programming language with probabilities
what's nice about it of course is the
explicit use of conditioning and the
explicit ability to do right those kinds
of things down in your models so many
people were interested in verifying
probabilistic systems so such systems
feature probabilistic components
protocols using randomization Bluetooth
controllers etc cell phones and so
people were especially people actually
building these verifiers we're looking
for ways to model probabilistic
transition systems as abstractions of
real systems and of course they were
also developing logics for reasoning
about probability so let me describe
briefly the label transition system you
mentioned already several different
probabilistic programming languages what
is the way how do we compare them before
your expressive power but what is the
honorable here for well expressive power
is always the standard by which you try
to compare them but mostly I mean how do
you compare existing programming
languages right you try to ask which
ones are the best for being able to
smoothly express certain kinds of
computations you want to do so what
happens in this world is it's a good
question because this is a subject
really informant right now people are
exactly having this argument and the
argument has to emerge from well what is
it you really want to do and what is
especially emerging from the people in
machine learning who want to use
probabilistic programming languages is
they want to write these models that
capture conditioning so it becomes
crucial for them that that's kind of a
basic feature of the language so in
terms of formal comparison in the sense
of a theorem like everything definable
in this is also definable in that such
theorems tend not to be interesting
because you can pretty much always do
that
bye you know some kind of fiendish
coding if necessary so it becomes a more
subjective thing about which language
you prefer to use or which how you
design the language
so let me define label transition
systems these were models of of things
that we are attempting to use as
abstractions of systems that we believe
have some probabilistic feature and we
want to reason about them talk about
their properties and about equivalents
so you have a set of states a set of
so-called labels or actions hence label
transition system and a transition
relation which is a triple like that
which takes a state and action in
another state it's typically not written
as a triple it's a one one likes to use
the label and to annotate an arrow and
describe this as a transition relation
so these transitions in general could be
indeterminate ok so the same transition
from a given state could lead you to one
of several different states and not in
any quantified way so these are called
non-deterministic transition systems all
right so we will write it with the label
on top of the arrow now probabilistic
transit so this was of course studied at
great length particularly by people like
Milner and others and they developed
Milner and park I guess and others and
they develop important fundamental
notions like by simulation when our two
states equivalent in their behavior and
you know other notions like week by
simulation etc in fact one ended up with
a zoo of possible equivalences for
discrete probabilistic transition
systems one it was just like an ordinary
label transition system but with
probability is now associated with the
transitions so again you have a set of
states a set of labels and for every
label you get instead of a relation you
get a transition probability matrix so
with every pair of states you associate
a number and that number you should
think of as the probability of jumping
from the start state to the end state ok
so you can think of this actually
perhaps better as state two
distributions over States
so this kind of model is what's called
reactive all the probabilistic data is
internal the which label is selected is
something that's left up to the
environment or perhaps the image you
want to use is of an experimenter coming
there and pressing buttons on your box
so that the system reacts to the
experiment that is being performed on
the system okay so we are not attempting
to associate probabilities with how
those labels are selected but given that
a particular label is selected this is
how the system reacts to it there are
other models where you also say okay so
these in these actions happen with these
probabilities so those are called
generative models i will look at
reactive models so here are some simple
examples of probabilistic transition
systems so for example the state s0 can
jump to s1 or s2 with the action a with
the indicated probabilities s2 can jump
to s3 with probability 1 under the
action a and over here you see that some
states s2 cannot do a transition with
the action see at all but s1 can and it
scatters you between s3 and s4 uniformly
as I said before we are not trying to
assign probabilities of doing an A or a
B so you have to probability one
transitions coming out of s0 so a will
definitely take you to s1 be will
definitely take you to s2 and I'm not
attempting to model with what
probability does a or b happen that just
happens and you are trying to express
how does my system respond to external
stimuli
okay so one of the things that we will
get into later on is the notion of
equivalent behavior of different states
of this system so this is the concept
called by simulation and the sort of the
deepest result I will try to show you is
a logical characterization of that by
simulation relation so what happens now
and in the recent developments is this
emergence of probability at higher type
and also conditioning as a basic
primitive so as I said back in 99 we had
already concurrent constraint
programming with probability so that had
probabilities and constraints and
conditioning but a couple of interesting
new languages have emerged church and
one court tabular so a church comes out
of the group at MIT so it includes a
because maan Singh heard an ROI and
others and tabular is from a Microsoft
Cambridge I think headed by Andy Gordon
and several others so the church people
will be here actually for the
uncertainty workshop and there will be
many interesting things that they will
talk about domain theory in conjunction
with probability I've already mentioned
saheb Jeremy back in 2002 Norman Ramsey
and avi pfeffer developed a kind of
monadic language for again an lcf type
language that work with probability who
go to lago who was also mentioned by
professor Scott this morning has done
many papers on operational semantics of
lambda calculi with probability baraka &
goo bowler hat have also developed
domains of random variables so there's a
lot of things happening now with
probability at higher type and of course
Dana's caught himself described this
morning showing that a model showing
that random variables can be introduced
into the lambda calculus
so these are all proposals and I would
say at this point there's quite a lot of
ferment and argument about what should
be the right models how should one
reason about these things what kind of
theories should one have and very
recently so less than maybe just over a
month ago at licks Sam Staten and his
co-workers presented as semantics for
reasoning and reasoning principles for a
higher auto probabilistic programming
language I found this to be a really
remarkable piece of work Sam will also
be here at the uncertainty workshop
talking about presumably about this also
at licks radu maud ra and I and Gordon
Plotkin introduced a new kind of
equation of logic so it works roughly
like this
we have the Equality relation that one
is familiar with we annotated it with a
small real number epsilon and it allowed
us to state things like you know some
term is with an epsilon of some other
term okay now you might think this is
just a naive hack surprisingly you can
actually develop a nice equation all
teary a nice analog of usual equation of
hairy using this idea so normal equation
of theories correspond to finite area
monads on the con set it turns out that
these things correspond to monads on the
category of metric spaces so there's a
nice in fact that theory develops in a
nice analog sorry so the key examples of
using this is for reasoning about
collections of probability distributions
probability distributions it turns out
you want to compare them and the and
typically make them into metric spaces
and there are very crucial metrics that
one uses to compare probability
distributions one of the most important
ones is called the kantorovich
Wasserstein metric so one of the things
we found is that that particular metric
can just be oxidized in a very simple
way with a few equations in this
generalized sense of equations so I will
talk about the kantorovich metric also
in some of my later lectures ok so this
is some of the recent work about
approximation now I want to close with a
bit of a shock which I got in 2011 so
this is a paper by and Nate Ackerman
Cameron freer and Dan Roy so what they
showed was that there is a pair of
computable random variables such that
the conditional probability distribution
is not computable so you can have purely
computa blida find measures you can have
computable conditions on which your
conditioning when you condition it and
the damn conditional probability that
you get is not computable so this is a
fiendishly clever encoding that they had
to do to do this
but I think for all of us it was a shock
so again this is creating some confusion
about you know you can't just allow
freewheeling conditioning in your
programming language you need to control
how we do it and so this is amongst the
things being debated and thought about
at this point okay so let me just end by
saying what's happening in the next four
lectures so as I said this lecture will
is somewhat short the next one will
perhaps we I'd be hard-pressed to press
it into an hour because I'm going to try
and cover one semester course on measure
and integration but perhaps I will
randomly select topics from within that
in the third lecture sorry hopefully boy
than that so in the third lecture I'd
like to present a particular monad that
is was eventually not eventually it was
originally proposed by louviere back in
64 maybe 62 it was never published there
are you know notes circulating with you
know type top and with people's
handwritten notes in the margins and if
you're in the inner circle you get your
hands on a copy of this but now now
these things are being publicized and so
you can get your hands on it but in 1981
Michelle Giri wrote a beautiful paper in
which she developed not just aloe vera
monad but a new one on polish spaces so
and worked out in some detail and so
this monad turns out to be fundamental
in everything that's happening now in
probabilistic programming languages and
reasoning about probability
probabilistic transition systems because
it captures the correct probabilistic
analog of the notion of binary relation
it's a binary relations are very basic
fundamental things you might ask so what
is the probability analog of a binary
relation it turns out to
emerged from this particular monitor no
no I'm not I will I'm not even going to
assume that you're familiar with the
power set category theory the second
lecture yes not a semesters worth just
just the first month in the third
lecture I'd like to talk about by
simulation or probabilistic transition
systems on continuous state spaces and
prove this theorem on the logical
characterization of by simulation so
such a theorem was first proved by
larson and school back in 89 91
depending on whether you look at the
conference of the journal version I
think 91 is when the journal paper
appeared but it was for a probabilistic
transition systems on discrete spaces
and it had a very strong assumption
which was that all the probabilities
appearing are multiples of some smallest
real number like so there's some
smallest number of point zero one or
whatever and every probability must be
some multiple of that some integer
multiple of that so it was a strong
finite branching assumption built into
it the logic had negation it sounds like
I'm trashing it but it was actually a
breakthrough result at the time so when
we started doing probabilistic
transition systems on continuous state
spaces we were not very optimistic
because you have finite branching
assumption this is not going to work if
you're looking at things that are
diffusing for example on the real line
absolutely not finitely branching in any
sense of the word how is this going to
work what even is the syntax going to be
like and surprisingly it turned out that
a logic simpler than the one that Larson
and school used suffice to characterized
by simulation even on these continuous
spaces it did not need any
those finite branching assumptions so in
fact because the discrete thing is a
special case of the continuous one it
was also an improvement of the discrete
results and it didn't use any of the
standard clever combinatorial techniques
that one uses in the discrete case
instead it used some remarkable
properties of analytic spaces and again
I'm not going to assume you know what
those are but those are a certain kind
of topological spaces that arise in
measure theory so this this is a one
proof that I will go through in some
detail and finally as I said it becomes
very important to metrics and measure
theory have a funny relationship you
know a priori you might think what the
hell is metrics have to do with it you
have measured here you have abstract
notions of Sigma algebra is defined on
arbitrary sets and you crank away why
should anything be why should metrics
play a role well two things happen so
measure theory works particularly well
on certain kinds of metric spaces called
polish spaces which are the topological
spaces underlying complete separable
metric spaces so metrics so measures
play well with metrics and you also want
to make your space of measures into
itself a metric space because it turns
out to be important to be able to
understand how close measures are and
the theory of metrics between measures
is a beautiful one and I think really it
came I mean there are many metrics or
one can define but the most interesting
and remarkable one is due to kantorovich
which was developed in the context of
mass transportation problems during the
war so kantorovich and his student
Wasserstein and his other student
Rubenstein developed this theory so this
is now available in the literature it's
quite difficult to track down these
names because first of all sometimes
it's called kantorovich metric sometimes
it's called passive stein metric
Wasserstein is spelled five different
ways it's presumably spelt one way in
Russian but it's transliterated into
english in
at least five or six different ways VW
apostrophes here there and everywhere so
it becomes a bit difficult to track this
down for a long time we used to call it
the Hutchinson metric because we learn
these things from Hutchinson's work
reading books on fractals but Frank fan
Bruegel who's very scholarly person
actually emailed Hutchinson and said did
you invent this and Hudson said no good
heavens it's been around for years so he
actually tracked it down and we've now
started calling it the kantorovich water
stein metric sadly the people in
computer vision also independently
discovered this metric but they started
calling it the earthmovers distance and
so if you try to find out you know if
you try to google this thing you will
find earthmovers distance now I think
drowning out kantorovich metric in the
number of hits you get so right so
that's what I will talk about in the
very last lecture I will introduce the
kantorovich metric or at least a kind of
discrete version of it and tell you how
to use this to define matrix between
Markov processes that measure their
behavioral similarity so things at zero
distance would be by similar and things
not by similar will be some distance
away ok and it turns out of course that
this will depend in some chance on this
logic logical characterization because
it will capture some of the intuitions
that come out of that logical
characterization all right so I will end
ten minutes early today but not tomorrow
perhaps I went ten minutes late tomorrow
who knows so are there any questions yes
but you started off with the analogy
between implication and conditional
probability something has always bugged
me is that there's a disability that you
can iterate implications but
non-traditional probabilities is that
somehow related to the issues and
compositionality and persephone trying
to do a probabilistic program
so I've never thought about it like that
so one doesn't try to iterate
conditioning in the typical
probabilistic programming languages that
are emerging out of the machine learning
community so when one is talking about
iteration there's more like you want to
iterate some kind of propagation rather
than than some kind of conditioning just
put tickets yes there is a dis analogy
on the other hand it's an only in
analogy not a perfect correspondence but
the analogy goes further then maybe I'm
selling it so I mean as you know there
is this vice category called srl which
captures some aspects of conditioning
and composing so anyway we'll see more
of these things okie on the 5k run for
you enjoy yes two questions what is they
does it really say that the joint
probability is not computable and
conditional probability but what is what
makes it so this is on continuous basis
so it's not the naive former Bayes rule
but and I know these guys I can find
[ __ ] you've done work on graph you it's
totally different from graph limits yeah
but conditional expectation conditional
probability so Roy is a machine learning
person and fear is a recursion theorists
so they got together and brewed this
health brew I'm not sure I understand if
it's on continuous spaces then what does
computable random variable mean yeah so
there is a all that one has to talk
about computer with real numbers and
things like this so so so such a claim
is not true in the discrete
well no definitely not I mean I mean I
yes certainly not in there according to
their paper know what i mean by discrete
world is not finite but countable so if
i have a captive random variable on
accountable sample space is there such a
claim I don't know I want to have to
check certainly their paper was not like
that but it wouldn't shock me completely
if it was even true in the countable
case and their computable random
variable presumably means I give you
some particular value that the random
variable so the probability that the
random variable is going to evaluate to
some particular value is computable
that's the price right clear and Roy
will both be here for the uncertainty
workshop so I think in fact Cameron is
going to present that in his talk
okay so if there are no more questions
maybe we should break and have a drink
Oh